yeah
intercepted off the coast of Libya on
Saturday these migrants followed a tried
and tested plan
set sail often with Smugglers and hoped
to be picked up by European Coast Guard
or charity rescue ship
but it didn't work out like that for the
perhaps hundreds of men women and
children who drowned when their boats
sank in these Waters last week
the Greek Coast Guard is facing
increasing pressure to explain why there
is a 15-hour window between it being
alerted about the migrant boat and its
eventual capsizing
families thousands of miles away like
those here in Pakistan administered
Kashmir want to know what happened to
their loved ones
who are on the boat
when their children's remains haven't
been found you can understand what a
parent goes through what's happening to
us we have no information whether
they're alive or dead we pray to Allah
let us see them again
no matter how many people drown there
are always more willing to take the risk
these men were caught in tubruck on the
Libyan Coast when released though almost
certainly try again to cross the
Mediterranean
not only a security one and it's not
only an economic or political dilemma
today we're facing a real humanitarian
issue that requires intensive
International cooperation between Libya
and all the countries concerned with the
crisis
so far this year more than 54 000
migrants and refugees have arrived in
Italy from North Africa by sea more than
25 000 came from Libya
but according to the un's migration
agency more than one thousand have died
or gone missing at sea
with Summer approaching and sea
conditions improving the number of
people attempting the dangerous journey
across the Mediterranean will only
increase and with that so will the death
toll now trainer Al Jazeera mesrata